m'appelle jos à céüse je suis
gestionnaire sur l'espace naturel
sensible des eaux de la rivière langevin
on appelle 4 blanc et gardes pêche
fédérale assermentés pour le compte de
la fédération départementale de pêche
le métier d'arbitré faire des missions
de surveillance les missions de
sensibilisation et voilà d'information
on est là aussi pour partager un peu de
passion aussi du milieu aquatique
expliqué aux gens
quels sont les bons gestes à avoir par
rapport aux milieux aquatiques
on essaie de faire passer des messages
de manière à faire respecter nos
rivières n'a aussi le volet police donc
ça ça une partie de nos missions d'aller
sur le terrain
contrôler les pêcheurs vérifier qu'ils
respectent bien la réglementation les
périodes de pêche toujours les quotas
qu'ils aient bien leur permis et
vérifier les différentes pratiques des
usagers dans le milieu aquatique
et
quand il voit un petit en avant d'aller
directement à lui pour vérifier que ces
pratiques sont respectueuses de la
réglementation
après ce avec les gardes pêche sont
aussi amenés à faire des études
notamment de recensement piscicole donc
on va des fois dans certaines zones
faire des appels des pêches électriques
donc avec un de matériel homologué qui
va paralyser le poisson et les crustacés
pendant quelques secondes
on va les récupérer pour les comptes et
les mesures et les identifier et faire
un suivi de population au savoir
appréhender le public à qui on a affaire
voilà c'est pas parce qu'on est garde
pêche qui va falloir tout de suite
arriver ni ruisseau si c'est interdit a
pas le droit de le faire faut avoir une
certaine rigueur c'est sûr qu'on peut
pas laisser faire n'importe quoi mais il
faut savoir aborder les gens et leur
expliquer petit à petit que peut-être
que leur pratique est néfaste pour le
milieu et qu'on peut faire autrement
après c'est un métier il faut aimer la
nature vous aimez marcher faut aimer les
plans physique parce qu'on est amené à
faire des missions de rempoissonnement
aussi du coup des fois on est amené à
faire plusieurs kilomètres avec des sacs
à dos avec 20 litres d'eau donc il faut
quand même avoir une certaine forme
physique pour faire ce métier là aussi
ce qu'on se rend compte que souvent il
ya des rivières qui qui en pâtissent un
peu des pratiques néfastes de surpêche
ou de pollution et on voit le taux de
population dans ces rivières là a
vraiment baissé alors que d'autres
rivières comme parent de la rivière
langevin qui est quand même plus ou
moins bien préserver les gens ont
conscience de la richesse de cette
rivière là ne font pas par n'importe
quoi et on retrouve des superbes
spécimens
de tout un panel d'espèces des kamas
ronde et cheva quine des chevrettes
grands bras des zombies c'est ça ce que
j'aime dans ce métier là avant tout
c'est de contribuer à la préservation de
ces espèces là et aussi le fait d'être
sur le terrain d'être toujours en
activité parce qu'on est amené à
travailler sur toutes les rivières de
lille donc on va aussi bien à mafate à
salazie donc serait moi qui aime la
nature je suis tout le temps dehors je
suis en contact avec
la faune la flore et voilà d'être au
coeur de la nature tous les jours c'est
un réel plaisir
que lui
il faut que le pêcheur prennent
l'habitude de se
s'informer sur les bonnes pratiques de
pêche nous souvent on invite les
pêcheurs à venir me voir la fédération
de passer un coup de fil
s'ils ont un doute sur les maisons de
pêche sur les périodes de pêche faut pas
hésiter on est là penseurs n'est pas là
que pour verbaliser
on est là aussi pour sensibiliser et un
peu apporter les bonnes informations
pour la bonne pratique de la pêche et la
préservation du milieu aquatique